James,
Mark Garber,
he says,
how can you be confident and courageous if your father was emotionally absent
and narcissistic?
I'm 21 and very creative.
My mother is a people pleaser who isn't confident in herself and uses me as
emotional support.
Help.
Well look,
you're confident about some things you said you were very creative
so you're confident enough to say that.
And you know,
I don't see the problem with questions like this.
I'm not criticizing your question by the way,
is that you're linking your lack of confidence and courage to the absence of
your father and his narcissism and also associating it with your mother being a
people pleaser.
So,
and you know,
there may be something to that.
Um,
it could be James that you could,
could stand to talk to somebody you know,
for a while on a regular basis and see if they can help you sort this out.
You obviously seem to think that this is a problem with you moving forward in
your life.
If you don't want to talk to someone about it,
then I would say the other thing,
you need a plan.
I know I always refer to that,
but it's the case.
You need a plan and then you need to break the plan down into this,
into small steps that are somewhat challenging,
that you have a high probability of nonetheless,
obtaining.
And then I would say by observing yourself,
move forward properly,
that your confidence will increase.
You're only 21,
you know,
so you're not that old.
But,
um,
that's the best I can do without having more information about the specifics of
your situation.